le muséum d'histoire naturelle de la
réunion les années 1830 1840 sont
marqués par la construction de plusieurs
édifices publics importants notamment à
saint denis
parmi eux la cathédrale la case anne
lambert et le conseil coloniale pour se
démarquer du pouvoir royal symbolisée
par l'hôtel des gouverneurs
les élus locaux décident de construire
le bâtiment abritant leur assemblée à
l'autre extrémité de l'axé principal de
la ville
afin d'accentuer sa mise en scène il est
érigé au sud de l'allée centrale du
jardin du roi la façade nord est
précédés d'un imposant portique à quatre
colonnes toscane monumental supportant
un fronton inspiré des temples de
l'antiquité ce portique embellie un
bâtiment rectangulaire d'une grande
simplicité en 1855
le palais législatif fermer sept ans
plus tôt est transformé en muséum
d'histoire naturelle c'est le premier
musée de la réunion
cette reconversion donnent lieu à des
aménagements intérieurs dirigé par
l'architecte pierre émile grenard
également auteur des plans de l'ancien
hôtel de ville de saint-denis
le plafond est surélevée et la mezzanine
créé sur le pourtour de la grande salle
centrale est doté d'un garde corps en
fonte richement ouvrages et en 1972
grâce à la richesse l'intérêt régional
de ses collections
le muséum devient l'un des treize musées
français classé au titre de leurs
collections
premier exemple à la réunion de
reconversion d'un monument en musée cet
élégant bâtiment néoclassique et
monuments historiques depuis 1978